whatsapp est utilisé par 1 milliard 500
millions de personnes le service de
messagerie prétend être sécuritaire et
confidentielles grâce à son système
d'encryptage des messages mais le
quotidien britannique financial times a
découvert que whatsapp avait une faille
que l'application a servi de porte
d'entrée à une attaque informatique
sophistiquée
c'est à peu près là la pire faille qu'on
peut trouver dans un système
informatique
c'est un sit in fine qui est qui permet
de prendre le contrôle du téléphone
les victimes de l'attaqué informatique
ont d'abord reçu un appel via la
fonction téléphone de l'application what
ça et même si elles n'ont pas répondu
déjà le logiciel d'espionnage avaient
infiltré leurs appareils à partir du
moment que votre téléphone est allumé et
il est joignable parce qu'il est
connecté à un réseau wi fi ou à travers
votre plan data jeu peut infecter votre
téléphone le nombre d'utilisateurs
touchés n'a pas été dévoilé mais il
s'agirait d'une attaque ciblée selon
whatsapp la taxe serait l'oeuvre d'une
entreprise privée qui travaillent avec
des gouvernements dans le domaine de la
surveillance
un logiciel d'espionnage développé par
la firme israélienne nso pourrait avoir
été utilisé pour perpétrer cette attaque
en fait le responsable premier de la
vulnérabilité ces voies sap
c'est un cancre inc and what samedi
avoir colmaté la brèche et évite les
utilisateurs à faire le plus rapidement
possible une mise à jour sur leur
téléphone une nouvelle tuile pour
facebook qui rappelons-le en 2014 avait
payé 22 2 milliards de dollars pour
acheter whatsapp ici vincent maisonneuve
rase au canada montréal